us we do have a little bit of a cool
down coming in for the weekend before
some hotter temperatures next week so
that's kind of the way the eight day
forecast is shaping up nice blue skies
this morning not much in the way of
winds temperatures are comfortable
outside we've got a lot of 60s a couple
of spots at 70 degrees downtown the
strip seven hills and centennial hills
just about everybody else in the 60s 59
out at red rock and some breezes up
there in the spring mountains 52 right
now at kyle canyon but we're going to
get some breezy to gusty winds really to
finish the week especially friday and
saturday the winds look to be stronger
there are no wind advisories that are
posted yet but we could get those winds
up 30 miles an hour or stronger both
friday afternoon and saturday afternoon
partly cloudy skies at times too and
highs that should drop to the low 90s to
start off the weekend then hotter triple
digits return later next week and the
reason for the clouds the reason for the
wind is there are a series of systems
pushing into the west and right now
we've got a ridge building that'll drive
temperatures up a little more today and
then these systems will kind of knock
that ridge down it'll relax a little bit
that will allow some of the clouds to
make their way into our skies and also
bring up some of the winds as we get
over the next couple of days so today
maybe just some east southeast breezes
not too strong up to about 20 miles an
hour uv index of 10 plus just means if
you're not protecting your skin with a
good spf sunscreen you're going to be
start burning and we'll look for highs
in the upper 90s as we get through the
rest of the forecast
tomorrow we'll see
clouds around mixed with sunshine mid
90s start to see those clouds increasing
probably tonight and stronger southwest
winds tomorrow into saturday that's
where we could get those 30 to 35 mile
per hour winds and temperatures do take
a little bit of a hit down to low 90s on
saturday mid 90s back on sunday and then
as we get into next week see the june
heat starts to set in and we're back to
triple digits wow 101 wednesday even 105
on thursday